foreign
[Music]
welcome to today's webinar
multi-dimensional approach to decoding
the mysteries of animal development
I am Matt Ashton of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genscript to learn more
visit genscript.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Justin Crocker group leader emblem
Justin you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is Justin Crocker and uh
today I'll be walking you through you
know kind of really what's at the heart
of a lot of what we research within our
group and what a lot of the field is
really motivated by to really explore
how genes are expressed across
development and evolution and how it
changes to these can actually result in
a variety of diseases as well as
beneficial things like changes in
organisms that contribute to very novel
features
um so what I'm showing you here on this
particular slide is really with the core
of our research which is fruit flies
right so really what's important here
and I'm going to walk you through a very
deep dive why we research something like
fruit flies why we think it's a very
powerful model system to really explore
much of the life and the biology around
us because what I'm showing you here in
the background these simple 80s G's and
C's these nucleotides that make up the
DNA that actually drives the gene
expression patterns of what you see here
which is developing Rio in this magenta
because it's actually the ball of cells
in a very very early embryo of a fruit
fly and what you can see is that these
ATS G's and C's which seem very simple
are sufficient to actually drive these
beautiful patterns of expression we see
during development right so that's
really that's something that's been the
heart for many researchers in the field
for a long time I'm going to walk you
through some of this history and again
because what we're really interested
with that our group is using this as a
model system now to connect how these
atcs and C's give arise these patterns
of expression and ultimately these adult
forms in this case of a fruit fly but
this could really be any particular
system
um right so how do you actually drive
these patterns of expression and how do
they manifest in this case is a fruit
fly
so really at the heart of a research
again is something known as
transcriptional enhancers and what I
want to walk through first now is you
know kind of the focus of why are we
interested in transcriptional answers
really what are they what are they doing
um and how within our group are we
studying these and then I'm going to do
a real deep dive and kind of you know
walking you through the actual
experiments we're doing within our group
and the new biology we think this is
revealing right so first what are
transcriptral enhancers in a very simple
ways you could see here in this diagram
transcriptional enhancers are these
little regions of DNA and what you see
in these long arrows then these arrows
are actually kind of these interaction
diagrams if you will right so these
enhancers what they're actually doing is
these little developmental switches that
will actually tell this particular
product in this case known as pole two
which that it's not really important but
really what this molecule is doing is
turning a particular gene on right so
these are structural genes right so this
could be actually in this case different
enhancers these switches could be
telling a particular Gene to turn on for
instance your eye or a limb or a leg
right so again what these are actually
doing now is
in this case for instance tissue the
enhancer a could be turning on in this
particular tissue type so if it's in a
vertebrate it might be the developing
limbs if it's in one of the fruit fly
embryos which you know we're studying
within our group it might be a
particular stripe
and then in some cases you may have a
different particular one that's turning
on a different tissue type right in this
case tissue B from enhancer right the
switch might be turning it on a
particular region now in the brain of a
developing mouse or it could also be
different stripes in the embryo right so
again the important Point here is that
these little developmental switches if
you will they're turning these on and
what we're really interested in
understanding is you know if we have
these stretches of DNA can we actually
predict where these enhancers might be
right this is the interest of many many
groups in the field and then if we have
mutations to these regions you know are
they actually going to change these
different stripes or change where your
driving expression during the brain
and the reason again we care about these
particular
things again right just to reiterate
this is very important throughout the
talk again these little switches that
turn genes off and on during development
um or just normal tissue physiology and
they'll do this actually by in this case
I have these little things labeled as
TFS what that means that's this shortcut
for transcription factors because
they're actually sitting there and
they'll bind to these switches and
they'll tell it to turn on or off in
particular tissue types that's really
functionally how they're working but
there's a lot more nuances to that as
we'll get
um to throughout the course of this talk
and what I also really really want to
emphasize is that we often thinks about
genes you know these simple little
protein coding things like structural
things again like hair or eyes or
whatever components there but the bulk
of our genome right if we look at all
these letters in our genomes right so
these millions and millions of base
pairs most of these are actually these
developmental switches and yet as I walk
you through our talk today we still have
an enormous amount to learn about these
so again why do we care right so what
functionally are these doing outside of
just turning things off and on during
development what I'm walking through Now
is really an examples of how enhancers
are actually driving Evolution and you
know which is at the core of much of
what we work on but a Counterpoint to
that is when things actually go wrong
which is actually disease
so first some nice examples of evolution
there's examples such as the prefrontal
cortex for um for instance invertebrates
right so big Invasion that happens as
you know we went from you know mice to
chimps and humans you know these
different phylogenies is that the you
know particular reads of our brain got
much larger and a lot of this is
actually thought to be driven by these
switches during development which is
actually encouraging extra growth of the
brain right linked to different things
like you know emotions and intelligence
right a lot of things that are thought
to be you know rather unique to to
humans in this case
there's other very unique things such as
you know in this case of euphyrians
which is another you know very
particular thing in this case for humans
which is placenta right so these are
entirely new tissue types and again
these are thought to be driven and arise
throughout the process of um what's
making us uniquely human through again
the gain of different developmental
switches right so again these are very
very important and there's many many
other examples across Evolution such as
in you know those beautiful pigmentation
patterns of fruit flies which again is
what we study we have different things
such as fish which is either Army armor
plates right so these actually change
between species so again each of these
are very very nice examples now of how
changes in these switches are really
driving a lot of the biology and I think
the beauty of life around us
and then I think these are other very
just you know kind of dramatic examples
for instance that the limb Evolution and
snakes right snakes actually lost limbs
at one point during um development this
again is a change in a developmental
enhancer right also things such as the
growth of bat wings right all these
beautiful different features and also to
come back against disease or different
changes or pathology that might manifest
during
um things that happen these different
systems these are also now Linked In
this case to over 90 percent of human
disease will actually are associated
with particular regions of these
developmental switches right so if you
change these very bad things can happen
in some cases but in the evolutionary
perspective you may actually have good
things that will happen and we'll kind
of continue throughout this during the
course of the talk today
um
and you know so really at the heart of a
lot of what we study and many many
groups is again this very very simple
relationship on the surface which is how
these ATS G's and C's right which I keep
kind of harping upon but what I'm
showing you here is that we actually
take this little strip this little uh
strip of DNA and we put this in front of
a reporter genes we call it in this case
these could be things that like gfp
green fluores and protein or other
molecules that actually light up during
the embryo like I'm showing you here
this is the early drosophila embryo and
you can see that what we actually have
on the left hand side in this case will
actually be the developing head and then
the other side will be the tail and you
actually have the belly facing up and
what you can see is these beautiful
beautiful Stripes that will arise over
and over again very reproducibly simply
by this little switch right so this is
actually the readout of where the switch
is turning on a particular Gene
and so what we're interested again is
understanding now kind of this textbook
example which I'm showing you here
because literally if you look up you
know from textbooks and all that you
have this very simple diagrams where you
might have you know a few little these
little molecules these transcription
factors that'll bind to these particular
regions of DNA and in turn they'll tell
it to turn on the particular region or
off in others right so it seems rather
simple on the surface right you just
have these little sites maybe you can
look for in the DNA which might predict
where it'll turn on but what I'm going
to assert right now and I'm going to
show you many examples of this
throughout the talk is that we cannot
build these by very first principles
right in other words if I just have
these collection of binding sites for
these transcription factors we put these
in front of a reporter Gene we typically
have nothing that I'm showing you here
that's really reproducible right so by
first principles we still have a lot to
learn as a community
and another major thing is that we
really struggle now as a community to
predict where these may be right so many
many of us could actually go out right
now and have our genome sequenced and
yet if we have just this very simplistic
sequence we can't just look at it and
say you know this is a road map for
building a system right we still have an
enormous amount to learn as a community
and this again is really what the
emphasis of both my group and many many
others around us were in my host
institution which is here at the MBL in
Heidelberg
right so really what we're focused on is
understanding what do we not understand
about these like you know these little
developmental switches why can we not
predict their activity and why can we
not build them
so really you know fundamentally it's
just what information are we missing and
these are very simple things I'm going
to walk you through using this as kind
of a case study you know for instance
how many of these binding sites these
transcription factors will sit down and
tell it to turn on during development
you know is it one is it two is it way
more than that
there's other things just you know how
robust are these if we start mutating
these right because if I already told
you that these are at least linked to
different diseases you know if we
actually go into these and mutate these
is it predictive and how often might it
cause different changes in disease
and then you know how do they contribute
to Evolution and the different
morphology that we see around us and
then ultimately again what many of us
are trying to do is now if we do have
this genome if our genomes are sequenced
how predictive is it for you know change
that might manifest as different
pathologies
so the reason I work on something which
might seem on the surface rather
ridiculous to many people which is fruit
flies as I'm going to kind of walk you
through this here and the system that we
actually use has an even more ridiculous
name in this case which is known as
shaven baby right and the reason we have
this very very crazy name and this is
something that actually kind of has a
history
um to it in the fly is that what I
showed you earlier these little cells
that are turning on during development
these little strips here these actually
link back to this very very classical
work which was done right here in this
um right down the hall actually by uh
Eric wish house and Yani Nielsen volhard
and what they actually did was a screen
that went on to actually win the Nobel
Prize here and the reason why they won
the Nobel Prize is they were working in
the very same system I'm going to walk
you through now and by doing this if you
see these little kind of wiring diagrams
above that embryo I showed you before is
these are all these very very classic
signaling Networks right so what they
were starting to do is if you mutate
different
um parts of this they're just doing
these random huge mutagenesis screens
and seeing how it affected the output of
these particular strikes I'm showing you
here and classically what they did is
actually looked at the larvae so very um
after the stage of develop it I'm
showing you the nice magenta here if you
see underneath this nature cover here
this is the work that again led to this
Nobel Prize because what they were
looking at now is these weird little
segments in the larvae which we know is
identical bands and really what these
are doing these are little hook-like
structures that allow the larvae to
crawl along in food right so any of you
had fruit flies in the kitchen you know
pretty horrible things can happen
depending on your perspective whereas if
you look in for instance your trash or
fruit as the rotting you know you have
these gross disgusting maggots crawling
around and the reason they're crawling
is all linked back to this particular
Gene that these groups of many others
have now been sitting for many many
years and I was a shaving baby because
again these are Little Hook structures
that allow them to crawl along
so again the important Point here then
after all that
um kind of lead-in is that we have these
eight different denticle bands again or
these hook structures and these directly
correspond to these different aspects of
expression you can see here labeled one
through eight right these are the same
little segments that we see during the
embryo so the important Point here now
is we have decades and Decades of work
many many different groups now who have
really been focused on understanding how
all these classic signaling networks
right now again I want to emphasize
these same networks exist in humans and
pretty much everything else we see in
nature right these are very deeply
deeply conserved networks and it's much
more developmentally how you kind of use
these networks and in this case how
these networks all are integrated at the
level these little simple
transcriptional systems what we're
walking through now is we don't actually
think these are very simple at all and
this has been a real challenge for the
field
so they're kind of unique Viewpoint we
took to kind of explore the space now
and again how these very simple
enhancers in the textbook Viewpoint
might work
um was to actually do a very very deep
dive here and really explore in a very
unbiased way how this information may be
distributed across the enhancer and
really key to that was the generation of
these enhancer libraries right and so we
took is that same 300 base per enhancer
and we just did a random two percent
mutation rate through this right so
again it's a very stochastic process you
kind of have a distribution where some
have one mutation some might have 10
mutations and by doing this
systematically over and over again we
had about a thousand independent
drosophila lines we put every single one
using the same reported Gene every
single one back in the same spot of the
genome right so it's super clean way to
go through and precisely measure how
individual changes in this switch might
relate to changes across development
um
and again I really want to thank the
sponsors for this gen script as you'll
see throughout the talk they're really
kind of the people in the providing much
of the infrastructure for this and they
were the first people a long time ago
which I mean this is a very very long
project for us as you'll see which
started maybe a decade ago now where
we've they've really been Partners who
are enabling us to build these libraries
and what I wanted to then do once we
have these libraries again to make a
thousand lines which I won't go into now
but always again feel free to reach out
to me after the talk I'm always very
very keen and very happy to discuss
these much further because there are a
lot of ways now we can put these back
into the fly in the same exact spot you
know really at scale so we can make
thousands of lines
and the next step after building these
thousands of lines is we actually had to
have ways to really handle many many
many embryos and really to do this at
scale very systematically so really at
the heart of this which I'll walk you
through very briefly is kind of this
automation system these robotics to
actually handle all the embryos for us
to again see where they're being
expressed during development and I'll go
a little further into this in a bit
um
because partis also Now is really by
doing the scale we really wanted to
treat this much more as if you will a
physicist would right approach us very
deeply very systematically so again now
we can relate very simple changes on the
surface to single mutations for instance
in the enhancer to these differences in
output in this case what we mean by
output is you see underneath this image
and quantification thing all these
little tiny little dots there each one
of these are actually a single embryo on
a slide and this is actually an enormous
enormous amount of data which again I'll
continue to walk you through really to
kind of impress upon you really the
power of scale and really what this is
starting to buy us as a community going
forward
so really at the heart of this initial
body of work was a lot of this robotics
here and there's a lot of excellent
collaborators my previous advisor David
Stern at Genelia and many other super
talented Engineers who helped us to
really you know enable a lot of this
technology because what this allowed us
to do is to take you know these fairly
simplistic fruit flies we could actually
put each individual line right so every
enhancer variant into a cage and you can
see these little Wells if you zoom in on
their individual Wells you can see it
underneath this little embryo heading
each one of those weird looking things
there is actually an individual embryo
right so you get lots and lots and lots
of these and what's super fun for us now
is we can actually take these little
Wells drop into the robotics here just
hit go walk away and it does all the
staining and fixing and all this other
stuff which previously
was not just laborious but it actually
you know these are really dirty dirty
assays in the sense that if you're going
to a thousand of these your ability as a
scientist to you know handle these
appropriately adding all the chemicals
appropriately is actually very limited
and Robotics actually afford us to move
past that point
and following a lot of the Imaging um or
the staining the next really key point
then was actually to ask saves through
the Imaging
and really at the heart of what I'll
walk you through here now we have the
ability through the robotics to actually
you know we take these we put multiple
Wells down to image these really at
scale and if you can see as you go
through this diagram here through the
automated Imaging and registration again
we could just take these well slides now
we can put a whole bunch down at once we
can do these overview images you can see
here again each of these little things
that look like a grain of rice in this
case in this case these are actually
each individual embryos and what I'm
going to try to play here is a video
where you can see that as you zoom in
now we can automatically go through and
take many many many pictures of these
and I'm going to show you here now in
green this is actually the full shaven
baby expression pattern and in the
magenta again is this is actually will
be where if you see the reporter Gene
the wild type one if you put it into the
embryo again where it will be expressed
in relationship to the full relationship
to the full expression pattern
um
so what I hope you can see now as you
rotate through this this is actually a
full 3d confocal projection now right so
these are very very rich very deep
powerful data sets for us to again to
query how you have changes enhancers
might relate to changes in this case of
these aspects of expression during
developments
and now what I'm showing you which I
think you'll see this video playing and
it's going to be a kind of insane amount
of data coming at you really fast and
that's kind of almost by Design it's
kind of like a shock and awe slide
because one of the most dramatic things
we found by screening all of these
thousand lines and I hope you can see
this in this video as it goes really
really fast here is that every single
line that we tested have a different
aspect of expression right so this was
to us very very jarring at the time and
totally totally unexpected
um right so again with this High
throughput embryology about us right and
you can get some of this is um the
references here so I'd be more than
happy to discuss that scale but really
what this allowed us to to do now is to
really again explore this enhancer in an
unbiased way and really again the very
dramatic thing the reason we think these
are so hard to predict and understand is
that every single line we tested had a
different aspect of expression
and I think
outside of kind of these insane videos
that go super fast right again you can
see now that there's a huge amount of
difference of this expression
but now if you actually slow this down
and then really look at all this breadth
of data what I have here now
um if you compare to Wild type you're
going to see that it has in the kind of
middle brand of these embryos wild type
has this very nice stripes the kind of
expression these very reproducible
striped embryo to embryo but now if you
go through all these different lines
each of these ones are Little Numbers
next next to them these are actually
single variants so a single nucleotide
is changed in these and what you can see
that again is very dramatic to us is
that every single one of these had a
statistically different level of
expression
and by using all this different
information I'm not going to go through
all this now because this is published
but what on the top I'm showing you now
is what we call a footprint score we're
able to actually go through now and see
regions of the DNA and in this case you
can see underneath that many is actually
associated with known motifs but in
others you can see that these footprint
scores really what it's telling us is
the probability that if we mutate
something here you actually have a very
like a collapse of expression right so
again there's a huge amount of
information through this at least from
this mutational perspective right this
was really for us was totally unexpected
um and this is why it goes on to be kind
of one of these fancy journals here so
what I want to walk you through now is
kind of just one little simple case
study to show again the power of these
type of assays by combining these like
synthetic approaches with all this DNA
the Gen script provided putting it all
into these systems and really exploring
the space
um in a very deep way because what you
can do now for instance here you can
zoom in as one kind of motif at the time
we had not explored further I'm going to
walk you through now and we can actually
footprint this and how we think this is
giving rise we mutate single nucleotides
again in this case will actually
collapse as expression patterns
so by zooming into one of these now you
can see in the top here what we this is
what we're calling coverage this is if
you just take this entire Library align
all these different sequences and you
can see these are just mutations per
site so you can see that we have a lot
of coverage and across a library we hit
every one of these different um
uh particular nucleotides across this
developmental enhancer
and now you can do a very simple thing
just say that you know if we go to our
library just pull out different random
lines in this case that have at least a
c mutation in one of these nucleotides
in some case they have others that are
distributed out but what I hope you see
if you look on that axis there I'm
showing you the activity right so the
log change
of different lines that have a c
mutation in different spots as enhancer
and what's still I think pretty
remarkable is you can see that there's
certain regions you can almost footprint
right shown in this case by these little
red bars that go down because if you
mutate these to a c in this case you
will have a very strong decrease of
expression
and now what I'm showing you um also in
these little highlighted regions one of
these here shown is in kind of this
green box and the other in magenta the
reason we've highlighted these in the
the green box is this factor which
really isn't that important for this
particular talk today but if you're a
fly you know affectionado in the
audience is one known as a Hox Gene for
Ultra by thorax which is another very
classic fly Gene but again the important
things that we knew this was a binding
site for a transcriptional activator so
it's kind of a positive control but we
also had these kind of new motifs that
popped up throughout this type of assay
known as these HTH or homothorax motifs
so what's quite nice is that we can
actually do now go in specifically
mutate in this case this ubx one this in
this case is positive control and we
knew that if by mutating this you can
see that if you compare the wild type
embryo to when we delete this particular
Motif you can see they get this really
dramatic
um just kind of crash out of expression
but prior to this we had no idea what
these other homothorax motifs which we
now know they're homothorax motifs but
prior to that you can see you can
actually footprint these type of regions
and now you can see that if you do the
same type of thing by mutating these in
the reporter Gene putting it back at the
Flying comparing it to Wild type again
you can see that similar to what we're
getting from these libraries you get
these super strong decrease of
expression by mutating this again so we
think this allows us to footprint these
different binding sites
and we can also do different things like
show how they're Cooperative which I
won't go into all the details now but
again by mutating both of these
particular sites now we can see that you
have in this case almost no expression
um actually there's a single little
nucleotide if you kind of zoom in there
on this one right so maybe you'll have a
single um sorry not nucleotide a cell in
the entire embryo now that is showing
expression when you delete these right
so clearly you can really identify you
can footprint sites
um I won't go into all details I'd like
to kind of just show this because
there's always some kind of like Old
Guard biochemist who wants to you know
validate all these so we can do this and
I really have to thank Richard Mann and
at the time this very talented
um postdoc in the group and we call Abe
right because they did this these are
really really hard because there's a
very low Affinity binding sites they're
in a non-canonical sites but they
clearly these transcription factors will
bind to them you mutate these and you no
longer have this binding activity and
furthermore was quite interesting for us
is that they'll physically cooperate so
you get these like super binding events
by having both of these sites
um so again I won't talk about this now
but if you want to go offline ask
questions about any of this I'll be more
than happy to address this
okay so at this point we've kind of gone
into what we thought on the surface is a
pretty simple little piece of DNA right
this little switch
but now we know that these are very very
dense there's an enormous amount of
information that we really did not
expect at the time
um and you know as I alluded to but I
can go into that deeply we think that
one of the reasons they're so sensitive
if you change individual nucleotides is
that there's a lot of cooperativity here
to make this like kind of a potent
switch right meaning that you have
different molecules interacting with one
another biophysically and now if you
disrupt this by in you know either the
interfaces or where they're binding a
DNA you just have this dramatic collapse
of um expression from these particular
regions
so really this kind of started us down
this road to understand you know if
they're this sensitive how evolvable are
they and again because a lot of this
relates to different things like disease
and many other conditions right so how
can we relate these changes again now in
more predictive context right it's kind
of one of the goals again for both our
group and many many others in the field
and before I go too deeply into this I
thought it'd be a nice kind of pause
inflection point to go back to really
one of the you know people who started
the entire field of evolution in this
case Darwin himself right so the concept
I'm going to walk you through briefly
here
um is something for developmental
biologists in particular Evo Devo people
or evolutionary developmental biologists
and this concept that Darwin at the time
um I would argue was talking about
developmental constraints when you talk
about something called Unity of type
right so this is a very old concept
where and I'm going to read you this
quote because I think this is kind of
you know this is very contentious in the
field people like to fight about these
things particularly evolutionary
biologists so one of the current
definitions and I'll kind of Punt this
to them
um but again I'd love to discuss this so
please get in touch with me after if you
like to you know further fight these
different viewpoints is that
developmental constraints are a property
of a trait that are possible in the
environment in which you're originally
involved acts to place limits on the
production new phenotypic variants and
the reason I'm showing Darwin here is he
noticed this relationship between the
size of the beak
um when he was looking at his classical
finches right so where it would actually
interface with the skull and then how
long that Beak was right so the scene
this very simple relationship that you
know which I think in hindsight makes
sense where if you have a longer beak
you need more support the brain you know
kind of the brain case where it's
interfacing the skull and this has
actually been formalized a bit now and
this is one of the classic classic
signatures of one of these developmental
constraints from the perspective of you
know us as evolutionary developmental
biologists and that you have again these
kind of linked traits where now if you
actually extrapolate these type of
principles in this case I think it was
buzzards actually not um finches in this
case but now you can see that across
many many many of these you have this
very tight linked relationship right
because they're kind of moving together
um in kind of this morphological space
if you will right so again while this
has been described for a long time
there's many ecologists right many
people go on the video collect specimens
make a lot of measurements you tend to
see these relationships all over the
place but really there is very little
molecular Insight or molecular
understanding of the underpinnings of
you know why we see these types of
Trends and these traits in evolution
so what we were interested now because
of what we're starting to learn about
these enhancers is do we see these type
of things or in other words does enhance
our logic Place limits on the production
due phenotypic variants do we see these
type of Trends in these linked
relationships
so one of the things I'm going to walk
you through is one of the first kind of
compelling examples of this whereas if
we looked at Wild type enhancers we knew
some of our previous work if you tuned
up these elements by increasing Affinity
right in other words how strongly when
these transcription factors could bind
and activate the expression of something
that quite often what we would get is
something that it wasn't just turning on
in higher levels where it's normally
expressed but I hope you can see that in
the kind of the anterior region is
embryos and many of the side cells right
this is that same factor I walk you
through the kind of the biochemical
validation I alluded to very quickly for
this Factor known as ubx but this is not
normally expressed all throughout the
entire embryo right so what's happening
is by increasing Affinity you start to
have activation not only that
transcription Factor but all sorts of
things will start clicking onto it and
turning it on inappropriately right so
again this is something that you do not
want to have happen because very bad
things can happen because this
particular Gene remember is actually
turning these particular cells into
these hooks structures and functionally
what this means is these cells actually
die right because they'll become these
little morphological hooks where most of
it's just faded now for cuticle right
something much like our fingernails
right so you don't want to miss Express
this in the wrong location because
clearly it's going to have a very bad
effect
and not only do we see if we turn it on
in these higher levels by increasing the
Affinity
um in the wrong place we also turn on
inappropriately early right so this
again is another thing that we see this
kind of relationship now where you have
many many bad things happening across
developmental in terms of the time the
spaces and locations here
so I'm not going to go into this too
deeply but again this is for people who
really are kind of committed to going
down this kind of quantitative route
like ourselves where you can actually do
now is go in the earlier embryos right
so a stage earlier were normally
expressed and what I have here in the
bottom here we can actually zoom into
these anterior or the introd enter
Stripes right so either kind of we call
these naked regions of the embryo where
you don't normally have expression or
you're normally showing expression and
what you can see at these early stage 14
embryos the higher Affinity one is
already starting to turn on
um in that Stripe Right so we label this
as a stripe at the stage 14 right so
this is actually the stage prior to what
it's normally turning on for um for
software developments and this becomes
even more exaggerated now
not Jesse worth normally expressed but
you can start seeing that in between
stripes now if you quantify this you see
this is turning on all over the place
right so clearly this could be quite bad
and then to take this a step further
what I'm showing you here in this kind
of 3D plot to kind of break this down
what we have now is the intensity kind
of going up and down the size of these
circles actually relates to the Affinity
right so what I'm showing you again in
the top
um just to remind you that if you have
the wild type you increase the Affinity
you start turning on it appropriately
and that big huge box is actually kind
of the extreme example I'm showing in
the top but all the others you decrease
the size of the Box what you start to
see again is this very kind of nicely
linked relationship that I alluded to
earlier right because now you see that
if you go from Wild type which actually
this teeny tiny very very weak binding
site that we think gets as an enormous
amount of specificity in this case so
it's uniquely binding only this one
transcription factor and there's
thousands of these typically that could
be expressed in any given cell right so
there's many transcription factors but
by having low Affinity we think this is
unique for this particular one but now
as you increase that Affinity you
increase the size of those you know in
this case these circles that are
representing that you can see that
you'll start turning on earlier in stage
14 for all of these this is also
associated with ectopic expression
outside these other zones right so again
you have this very nice linked
relationship
and we think that I won't go into this
again now but we think that as you go
for a specificity versus Affinity as you
increase its Affinity kind of this this
tuning that I'm showing you here what on
the top this actually starts to do is
that these other transcription factors
actually start to compete for these
different sites
um so such that things that normally
would not bind and will stick there and
they're turning a switch on all over the
place in the wrong locations this is why
you get these kind of crazy expression
patterns
and so one of the other things we were
quite obsessed with at the time is to
see you know how far can we push this
not just from these transcriptional
activators right because you can imagine
it's kind of easy to make something
stronger or weaker but one of the things
that we knew going all the way back to
the original screen is classic
Heidelberg screen if you will and so you
have these really interesting mutants in
this case known as wingless again the
identity is not really that important
but this is like TCF or some of these
other ones for more vertebrate systems
but what's interesting about this is we
know now there's a transcriptional
repressor and this is what we learned
about this and one of the reasons we
first identified this or the others in
the community not myself but if you
mutate this Gene product you instead of
having this nice clean Little Hook
structures right I hope you can kind of
see that here where you don't have these
naked regions now if you remove this
product you can actually get a lot of
these and it turns out what this is
doing again is it's making these naked
Patches by actually functioning as a
repressor and you can see that I hope in
this diagram here these little hook like
structures these are actually the kind
of this cartoon version where normally's
enhancer is the magenta here these are
each little individual cells that are
represented in this diagram here where
some actually have the cuticles for
shaven baby
um the reason it's not expressed
everywhere is you have again this
morphogen gradient or this areas of
expression which are going to Signal
actively to turn it off and in the
enhancer what we noted and I hope you
can kind of see this now that the motifs
for that that are effectors for this are
actually oftentimes overlapping directly
with some of the transcriptional
activated we found right so they're kind
of competing for a site so we were
curious about you know the consequences
of this because we in our collection we
never had any examples of this big lawn
of cells right and we were curious why
we were not getting that
so we've spent a lot of time looking at
this and one of the major things we
found is that every time you would touch
one of these binding sites for the
transcriptional repressor because it's
directly overlapping one of these
activator sites they're always coupled
meaning that I hope you can see on the
right this line known as e3n 97-3 is one
of these variants in the library so now
we have a single mutation that repressor
binding site but by kind of augmenting
the um directly vicinity of this
homothorax that other site that I talked
about earlier right so we knew that if
you mutated this site you collapse
expression but even mutating something
in a neighborhood will also collapse the
expression right so I hope you can see
in this particular line now that where
your normal Express goes down you start
turning on a little bit in between cells
but it's coupled always with the normal
expression going down
and we can actually go through and
quantify this where again the wild type
now at the very high levels by this bar
graph
um this is actually where it's normally
expressed and next to it now the very
low one is the wild type one showing the
expression in between the segments this
naked region and you can see it's
normally very very much off in this
naked region
and we could actually extrapolate this
further now really showing that
across many of these red lines we have
the same um thing that we found for this
particular Amber on the top but now if
we mutate this repressive Zone you
always couple this with a little bit of
ectopic expression in between but it
always comes at the cost of your normal
expression Zone really dropping right so
again these very very linked
relationships we see this across many
many different variants right we can
keep doing this ad nauseum if you will
because again the really kind of potent
thing we found here again is the linked
relationships now where the reason we
couldn't get that lawn of expression is
because every single time we started
mutating this the normal expression
would decrease right such that you know
we could never get expression throughout
the entire embryo
and with everyone actually further and
said okay now if we think we understand
the system by doing this really at scale
if we go out into the wild and look at
many many of these variants what do we
see
um right because the prediction was we
should never actually see a lot of
trichomes ever in nature If This truly
is manifesting now as a constraint
um right again it's very linked
relationship
and so we actually did this we went out
and gathered many of these they're like
over 50 variants and a lot of this um
was David Stern and others who've got
many of these lines together so we had
to you know millions and millions of
years of evolution and really the
Striking thing is we found is very
consistent with that very simple
hypothesis based on this constraint we
think we never ever had expression in
these zones right and here's a few
different examples and the top is
melanogaster the one we work with is
like the common fruit fly but many of
the others you can go from you know the
desert and the us or different regions
throughout the world we never had
expression there so again we think that
you know going back to Jacob and many
others that you know his particular
quote was that these are adaptively
coherent patterns and we think that by
doing this at scale as we walk through
this example here we hope to identify
men's patterns
so at this point I hope I've kind of
convinced you that you know this is a
textbook example of enhancers but we
think that these are incredibly
information dense
um you know so it's much more something
like this right it's just blanketed with
information many of these are probably
transcription Factor binding sites we
haven't identified there might be other
structural elements to it in terms of
the rigidity of DNA a variety of other
things so again there's a lot of
information here where we think as you
mutate it this is having a dramatic
effect
and we're kind of interested exploring
further how common are these constraints
because I think you know for many
different perspectives could teach us a
lot of biology
so I'm going to walk you through now a
little bit about looking at other
tissues other enhancers before we go to
um you know kind of wrap up the talk
and I'll go through this a little bit
fast it's an interest of time but again
always ping us because some of this is
already out in pre-prints but one of the
things we noted in terms of constraints
is again we focused a lot on these kind
of nice patterns here of this one known
as shaving bid which again now I'm
showing you here in green but we found
it across our entire collection not only
did we never see it you know in between
these Stripes as I walked you through we
also realize that we only saw it in
particular cell types where Shane maybe
was normally expressed right so you have
these different variants that I'm kind
of showing you examples of you know
different posterior kind of the bum of
the embryo which some it would actually
be developing wings so you know go on to
be Wings later on but the important
Point here is that these are all
patterns of expression in Native zones
where shaving babies normally expressed
right so something fundamentally
important we think is happening here and
it actually quantify this in this 3D
plot here we just kind of parse it apart
and kind of these classic tissue zones
right these these germ layers if you
will we're we found is that as you
mutate all of these different variants
which I'm showing you here kind of going
up and down every single one of these
was limited solely to this particular
ectodermal tissue zone right we never
had anything in the mesoderm or the
endoderm or any other classical tissue
types right so in this case it was kind
of shocking to us because you know I
kind of grew up intellectually thinking
that enhancers were kind of you know
simple switches you can turn on and get
easy expression anywhere but at least
from these standing elements the ones
that are in the genome doing something
important already by mutating them it's
kind of biased already
right so again we're curious if it was
General so I'm going to go you through
this a little bit quickly again in
interest of time but this goes back to
this very classic Concept in
developmental biology where shaving
babies known at the kind of this
differentiation Cascade this goes back
to kind of Waddington and many classic
um biologists have been kind of building
upon this where if he has a little
marble in this trough kind of this
metaphor is that as you go down your
marble is going to kind of start
differentiating and then it gets kind of
locked in so it could be that shaving
baby again is this terminal selector
Gene which is going to fate the cell to
its final form then maybe it's so
sensitive because it's some kind of you
know way the switches are set up for
something that is very late in
development so maybe if you go earlier
in this case it's mid or early in the
embryo and I'm going to walk a few
examples now to see if we see the same
type of patterns
um right because maybe they're less
hardwired they're a little more plastic
and they can move around
um so this is another classic drosophila
enhancer known as a 10 man enhancer and
and you can see that this kind of
beautiful
um expression patterns now and kind of
yellow diagram so these are the zones
where again this reporter Gene chose X
drives expression in developing muscle
types and we think that we know quite a
bit about this you know many of these
binding sites but what we found again
going through this through these similar
enhancer libraries is that we mutated
this there was one huge amount of change
of expression right so many many sites
outside these canonical motifs or
previously explored but again everything
was limited to this one tissue type only
in the mesoderm right so this we think
is still fundamentally very important
and we again just never saw it turning
on in like the nervous system or any
other tissue type right so this is
pretty hardwired in this system
we've actually explored this to many
other enhancers such as this very early
embryo one one that is like one of the
first times the mesoderm is actually the
developing muscle will be marked you can
see here in this blue pattern and on the
right is kind of a schematic because at
this point it's actually the embryo is
the ball of cells this is like that as
early as it gets pretty much when the
Faith's really being assigned so this is
actually showing a cross section of this
so twist is a particular Gene and this
particular enhancer The Twist PE element
not really important but is it a switch
it turns it on
um and another one of these is just kind
of these stripes on the embryo right so
we have these different ones the stripe
will actually be turning on developing
nervous system
and what's important for us is we have
these again classic classic enhancers we
think we understand these binding sites
but consisting with everything I walk
you through before now as we build these
libraries test these enhancers in Vivo
what we found now is as we mutate these
when we actually now assay the levels of
expression different zones right I'm
marking it here as the exoderm mesoderm
is endoderm kind of the proxies to see
you know how mutable and what kind of
space can these enhancers move around in
what we found
which I still think is quite striking is
that again twist was only limited to the
mesoderm or it's normally expressed we
didn't get any extra expression
um in this case same with uh this other
enhancer which is in these nice Stripes
which is developing nervous system for
this one known as rhomboid but again
everything was limited to these normal
patterns of expression which to us was
quite shocking because I think there's
an enormous amount for us to still learn
here
and I won't go into this any further in
this case in the interest of time but
when I can also impart upon you is that
it's not like it's impossible because we
can actually add in a lot of synthetic
activation here and kind of boost it all
the way up but we found at this point
now is that actually
even through this it's possible to turn
on these zones with the most potent one
of the most potent activators we know
but it's still really really difficult
you go from you know we can go for one
or two or three binding sites that we
add in onto this enhancer and just
ubiquitously Express the activator ever
with the embryo and even here it's very
difficult to turn on these inappropriate
tissue types
right so clearly
um these you know there's another
classic enhancer I forgot to put this in
here but I'll go through this an
interesting time again this is literally
a textbook enhancer so if anybody's
taking developmental biology class
you've learned about something known as
even skip stripe to enhancer
um literally you can go look at you know
I have this textbook sitting up here
next to me the molecular biology the
cell all the identity is not important
but again Decades of work we think we
understand the binding sites and when
I'm marking this little cartoon of the
schematic for The Binding sites next to
this enhancer which gives us beautiful
beautiful very precise stripe through
what you can see this number of
signaling Pathways from this textbook
what we know now is that just like every
other enhancers you mutate is Randy with
single mutants a lot of it just
collapses right so there's a huge amount
here
and we think that these are really
functionally constrained these elements
and so what we really became interested
in now is what other forces from an
evolutionary or a disease or any other
perspective might be shaping and driving
different expression if you can't really
mutate these where does it come from
so for this again um janscript actually
ended up providing us this very nice
library of totally random sequence right
so we could put this through the
pipelines those sequences never seen
selection we you know it's really
doesn't have anything you know impinging
upon is Fitness so now if we test these
totally random patterns of DNA what was
really shocking to us then is it under
like the things that we're mutating now
if you just look at where they're
driving expression during the embryo
these things really go crazy
um and this again if you can see that
um kind of this pie chart right here
um in this case about 36 percent of
these drove Expressions somewhere in
development and many of these examples
here these are each individual lines you
can see there are different spots some
are turning on and developing intestine
they've got the head the ectoderm all
over the place right so there's very
high robots of expression so we were
kind of shocked about this so we looked
at these different pieces of DNA because
we in this case had many of them
um right because this is what you can do
with these type of libraries and then we
could pull out individual motifs in this
case the individual factors aren't
really that important here but you can
see that every time it had some of these
motifs they actually had expression
particular tissues right so gotta Ease
on the top is one that's known to be
expressed in the gut and every single
time in the developing gut you get this
beautiful expression at very high levels
this is actually Associated this Motif
right so pretty much everything or in
this case every single time and there's
another one known as grainy head or grh
here the same thing right it's turning
onto the ectoderm so we are interested
then if why these chemotifs are
associated with developmental expression
and in this case what we ended up doing
is that we had this hypothesis that
there's these classes of factors that
most of DNA is kind of very wrapped up
in these little nucleosomes so nothing
might have access to it so maybe what
these particular motifs are associated
with active expression are doing is
they're binding sites for these classic
factors that have this Pioneer Factor
activity where they can bind open up DNA
and then let everything else bind to it
and we think that this is potentially
what's happening because you need these
two different classes one that's
controlling the kind of the on off or
the state and then the others are kind
of the levels are dictating where you're
being expressed
right so we're curious then very simple
we do Pioneer factors regulate these
elements and we biases with the two
classic ones from drosophila again that
grainy head that I alluded to another
one is Zelda the names aren't really
important but again the important thing
is that they're well characterized
Pioneer factors
and what we could do then is now do the
same libraries in this case bias it with
the chemotif Zelda's globally expressed
now so now we have a new library we have
a totally we have a bias Motif in the
middle sandwiched around totally random
sequences
and now it's quite exciting about this
now he has a huge amount of expression
in this case it goes up to about 88 of
them are driving active expression and
you can see some very nice examples of
this so this is robust it turns on like
Midway through embryogenesis
and what's really nice now is you get
this beautiful range it's turning on all
over the place right so we know it's
expressed broadly very early and it gets
refined in the ectoderm so we think that
you know this really is a way these
sequence spaces are being explored
potentially through Revolution
and we can go even further with this
another example this grainy had one and
this for us again it's expressed in the
exoderm so we made another bias library
and what's really powerful about this
for us is you get a hundred percent
which for us is a very rare number to
hit in biology which tends to be a
little bit messy but 100 of these
actually drove very nice expression kind
of off in these stripy patterns
throughout the developing embryo
exclusive in the ectoderm in this case
where it's normally expressed
and then we're interested further saying
you know if we look in the genome can we
actually get evidence that they're
actually driving
um this adaptive potential and I won't
go into the details of this but the
important thing is that we found these
regions that are exclusively these ubx
binding sites that we knew from Chip
we're binding um these rates at very
high levels and what was important is
that these are exclusively found only in
drosophila melanogaster so no other
fruit flies that are closely related
right so they we think presumably they
arose recently through de novo Evolution
that kind of came up through like
mutational processes
and what was quite striking is we tested
these they all drove expression and
furthermore we think of these could be
material for evolution now because we
mutate these binding sites at our rows
kind of de novo these Pioneer sites
we see that you actually collapse
collapse expression in some of these key
tissue types right so again we think
that what is happening is that clearly
these new sites have this potential to
drive expression
and we think going all the way back to
kind of you know the functional thing at
the beginning of talk why do we think
these are important is that what we
found now is if you look at many
different case studies right so these
are often just you know small sample
size some like these massive things
we've been building but again brain
Evolution placenta limbs armor plates
now we know that many existing elements
so limbs actually come from the breaking
of one of these switches right you lose
this element and that's why you lose
limbs and fish you lose these armor
plates because you break one of these
elements like literally at a region in
the genome it's kind of a hot spot for
mutations
and then
a Counterpoint to that as many novel
elements in this case oftentimes through
transposons or de novel Evolution
um in particular like the placentas
transposons that are hopping in the
genome they're turning on genes at
different tissue types and we think that
this is really driving a lot of adaptive
potential and also an mammalian brain
right we see that these regions are kind
of these hot spots for Rapid Evolution
right so we think these are all novel
elements and they're often not standing
variation right so we think that again
these are very general principles are
starting to find by going at scale very
systematically
and so I'm going to end most of this
right now just kind of at this very
final Viewpoint I kind of want to assert
this very very quickly because you know
a lot of what we've been walking through
is connecting
um genotypes to phenotypes throughout
this talk right in this case there's
reporter genes
right so we do a lot of Robotics Imaging
automation at scale we think this buys
you a lot of statistical power
and you know we can publish this we can
learn a lot of nice cool things that a
lot of the work I already walked you
through again is a buyer archive paper
so feel free to look at that but what's
been frustrating for us and much of the
field now is we're still because you're
a porter jeans where we're still trying
to struggle how to connect this to how
they might manifest as the adult
how in different environmental
conditions they may change so a lot of
kind of what we're doing kind of the
call to the community right now these
what we call Grand challenges in terms
of connecting genotypes to phenotypes at
scale right we think this is one of the
most challenging things to do as a
community and I'd love to keep taking
questions further because you know from
the genotype perspective this is very
easy for us to solve now right any one
of us can get our GM sequenced we can
sequence any of these little critters
out in the wild
but now connecting this in a meaningful
way to things like you know predictive
gene expression metabolism
um cell or tissue types and you know
going even further how these manifest in
external things like morphologies or
behaviors and then really how they you
know different environments how they're
robust are they the temperature the food
Choice all the many different things
this is what we're really trying to go
after so a lot of what we're doing in
the group and I really really want to
emphasize we'd love to discuss this this
is where I give these type of talks is
that where you know we're going for
these very high dimensional data now to
really explore this at scale we call
this um developmental phenomics we're
now working with people like genscript
and others we can actually go and do
very discrete synthetic manipulations
right at the genome or doing things like
crispr many new techniques we're
continuing to push within the group so
now we can actually start through a lot
of multi-omics you know every other kind
of classic ohmic you can get your hands
on to really now give us this huge
dimensional data sets to connect these
different scales this is what the goal
we think of our group and where the
field is really headed and you know then
we can actually do uniquely and
drosophila see how these will actually
change using laboratory Evolution over
time
and again I'm going to walk through this
very quickly because I know we're kind
of coming up to time but a lot of what
we're doing now to kind of relate this
back to our talk we're taking fruit
flies now we're doing you know in this
case transcriptional enhancers we're
sending this many other things to really
see as we work with people like
genescript can we build these synthetic
libraries at scale can we do this now
actually in the genome can we relate
this you know by using Robotics and
automation to do this at scale can we
you know image through this doing these
different pipelines you know because we
walk a few kind of nice examples earlier
right so we can get a lot of data now
and really what we're starting to do in
the group now is pushes much much
further and now connect it's not just a
simple gene expression but to other
things that are intimate related like
metabolism so we're doing spatial
metabolomics and this is actually a
larvaeum showing you here so now we can
look at 100 metabolites across
populations of larvae we can do
different things like single cell
genomics we can do animal behavior in
the fly and really what we're quite
excited about
um you know I hope you can see the
animal behavior right because these are
little crawling larvaees I alluded to in
the very beginning and much of the talk
right so there's a lot of data here and
now we're actually tapping back into a
collagen Evolution and see how these
change over time and with that um again
we think developmental phenomenals will
be very very powerful to teach us how
these genomes are working and I would
love to discuss this further I'll stop
here and think an enormous amount of
people who helped us
um and again we do have positions
available because two of my first you
know fantastic postdocs just walked off
they got their dream positions so great
for them we're still kind of reeling but
you know we're really on the hunt for
other people who you know kind of share
enthusiasm in our perspective to kind of
take the science much further and
although that'll stop and take any
questions
foreign
thank you Justin for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask the question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started Justin it looks like
we have just one question here for you
oh we got two that came in let's see
here first question will be you might
mentioned this during your talk
but how did you determine the mutation
rate for your enhancer library and how
important for enhancer Library being
unbiased
oh it's a very good question yes so for
us the mutation rate was actually
between two closely related fly species
at the time
um so we thought it was a good kind of
aim to hit towards something that was
actually represents and we'd see in
nature
um and for us the unbiased angle is
actually very important because we
wanted to explore all the possible kind
of landscape to these changes and how
they contribute to possible change of
gene expression
okay
Just One Last Question came in here for
you uh question reads if mutating the
two HTH domains abrogate's expression
nearly entirely what are other domains
contributing
oh very good question so we didn't have
time to go into too much of that but
there so there's actually specific cells
you'll start losing expression in for
different transcription factors or
different signaling Pathways so some of
them have very precise changes
um at spots within the embryo or
timing-wise in embryo
okay well I appreciate it I think that
was all the questions that we had time
for today
uh I wanted to say thank you again
Justin for your time and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor jenscript for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time
goodbye